that was 100 inches of snow in your
forecast no it was not that is just an
amazing number up there has a really
impressive they're really just one
snowstorm away from being there all time
snowiest winter like you just mentioned
there what's the cold weather doing the
commodities markets it's really
interesting it was a really slow start
to this winter I've been calling it a
last-minute winter just here in the last
month februari has really cranked up and
natural gas which it had gotten a
sluggish start this winter particularly
compared to last winter has really
picked up the pace in terms of demand
and the overall pricing and everything
it's gotten a lot more interesting this
februari is on track for the u.s. to be
the coldest since 1979 Wow so you know
we we had a relatively warm December but
here in February I think we're all
waiting for spring now but it's been
really impressive does cheap oil change
the energy mix in winter yeah it you
know I wondered about that as well I
wondered about the you know everything
was really cheap even natural gas is
really cheap so you just wonder there's
not much of a conservation effect and
with so much cold I mean it's it's right
now as we're talking it's three degrees
below zero in Chicago it's 11 degrees
below zero Minneapolis they're really
having a tough go of it out in the
Midwest and and natural gases has been
relatively cheap particularly compared
to last year with with the amazing
supply that we have right now Matt how
will this affect markets next winter do
people when they're when they're
thinking about plans for the coming win
or do they just think back to the last
one are they actually looking at the
data how sophisticated that analysis
yeah it's a little bit of both I mean
they certainly last winter's a huge
benchmark and last winter was a big
winter all together but right now
they're trying to figure out what the
end of season storage number is going to
be before we start moving back into
injection season again starting to
resupply the natural gas surplus
situation but the math has changed
because this week was really cold and
and in the next week coming up and then
the first week of March is going to be
really cold as well so they're having to
reanalyze the data to try to figure out
what our end of season number is going
to be to set the stage up for the summer
and that sets the stage up for next
winter so there's a lot of pieces of the
puzzle that have to be figured out now
Lisa brownridge still on set with us who
covers fixed-income brilliantly for
Bloomberg News Lisa the story of 2014
was blame the weather blamed the weather
that was the reason we saw this sharp
fall on GDP in the first quarter Lisa do
you think we're gonna see that again
this year well so far actually the data
has been fairly positive all out and out
so people are actually saying despite
the weather the net economic sort of
outlook seems to be more positive and
you are seeing that reflected meals at
this point this month are rising but yes
I would imagine that that will still be
used as an excuse because why not blame
the weather Matt we've been looking at
pictures of Boston we've been talking
about 100 inches of snow there but this
winter has affected power markets all
over the country right yeah certainly
there's been a lot of a lot of demand on
the power side as well the pjm market
which is like the mid-atlantic the West
pjm which goes into the Midwest this
morning the hot down in Texas are
dealing with frozen precipitation in
Dallas there's been a lot of demand
spikes on the power side too but it's
really just been the last three weeks or
so it hasn't that the first half of this
winter has been fairly quiet just just
here in February it's really picked up
Matt can I just ask you a very quick
controversial question as a professional
meteorologist do you believe that humans
are causing climate change I believe
there's definitely some influences of
being involved there but yeah I'm a
little bit cautious on some of the
climate models I look at models every
single day and you know there's a lot of
limitations to what the science can do
in terms of predicting the future so I'm
a little skeptical about the details on
the models but I agree there's some
things going on